but hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John Humphrey we are going
to watch today a video that is probably
cut up Elton John and Taron Egerton the
Elton John AIDS Foundation Academy
Awards viewing party not only they sing
tiny dancer and apparently Kingsman to
won every Oscar at that party that's
crazy special feed it was crazy
they did talk a lot about AIDS in
Kingsman - and that was Julianne Moore's
motive the whole movies about to
eliminate AIDS yeah I don't know why
they stopped her it's unfair one of our
top of work here's a patreon is whatever
video you request we must do it put up
on YouTube service for you guys this
comes from Chris may Lou Canadians son
of a B with an awesome YouTube channel
new stal juh goes over games that he
really loves die sex them the fantastic
videos and he's also a fantastic
photographer may you photography I'm
telling you he takes photos of some of
the hottest men and women more than
women but there are cavemen there's some
very attractive women here you're very
lucky guy my god let's just react to
these oh yeah we're filming a video
that's right he is such a good-looking
guy [ __ ] [ __ ] doubt sings
[Music]
Wow how kids cygnus in front of Elton is
great and wit on stage everyone about
your iPhone yeah literally every I need
proof that I was there
[Music]
that smile
now this ah sir sighs River
[Music]
you get a little nervous or maybe this
is a little stiff in his body language
but that go ahead you can see buddies
are great yeah
[Music]
it's how you sell your boobs yeah ah
musical chemistry start
[Music]
haha here it's a ratio
[Music]
Oh God
crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome ocean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
play off a little bit there I was I
think I was doing the harmony you're in
this cameraman together it's been done
for a movie like I know it's for an AIDS
Foundation but you know what I mean
this is how about the movie a hell of a
lot of yeah I am now aware of AIDS Oh
buddy
gosh it's cool man really couldn't me
get this out of the way I get so annoyed
when everyone what's out there I I'm
like oh don't worry you'll be able to
find this footage of better quality
somewhere else
yeah if you want to like snag five
seconds to prove that you were actually
there that's one thing if you're like my
friend like if you're like when you did
music I that one show I'll record you
the whole time for you for something
like this so just be there yeah I mean
if it's a set or something it's like I
understand take a couple pictures yeah
it's like grab the passage of that song
that you love but be here the rest of
the time it's just like I know that so
reviewing whether you're gonna find this
everywhere and there's gonna be a better
quality don't worry
yeah they're in the Mona creative memory
in this in this content I'm like you
notice you don't snap a picture and
check it out later we first got this
video sent over to us I thought was just
tearing a gerson scene and then it
wasn't the title for us I'm like Oh
Elton John's adhere to it really seems
to like Terra nitrogen they must be buds
Tom Hardy was actually supposed to play
elton john and and he was he was
contracted for it for a long time well I
know Tom Hardy was very vocal being
nervous to sing because he doesn't even
feel he'd have confidence in his voice
and there was nothing confirmed like oh
he dropped out cuz of that or scheduling
conflicts I never confirmed why he left
but as very obviously they started up a
kinship on at least Kingsman
this is insane to me on just a variety
of levels well you
it's it's all--it's yeah it's kind of a
mine vendor because it is the star and
the subject and it's already kind of
strange that we're having these biopics
especially for Elton John it's like with
Bohemian Rhapsody is a little different
because it's partly like the Freddy
movie and Freddy he's not here anymore
but Queen is and now you Janell tinge on
is his movie he's producing and he's
here yeah singing with him and I feel
like that is a tremendous vote of
confidence at for the movies but he's
giving the spotlights a-tearin for this
yeah he's hot and he's harmonizing with
him and he's letting Taran prove himself
I'll be up here on stage with him but
he's gonna sing love Dallas I'll back
you up I'll play the piano but you're
gonna sing the song turns a professional
but he must be he must have been at
least slightly aware of more than the
trailers and more than the movie this
live performance is gonna be the way to
prove myself yeah that if I'm gonna be
performing this in front of Elton next
to Elton instead of Elton this is where
everyone judgements Ally is gonna be on
me if I don't win it the next time real
and then it's just a fan of Elton John
I got imagine how freaking nuts that
must be for this guy you know yeah
unless he just didn't ever listen Elton
John until this point it's like yeah I
don't really have any personal
attachment to Elton I didn't know his
music till I was much older I mean I saw
that performance with Stan you know and
Eminem and all that but I didn't know
his music till I was on Kingsman with
him one day he played a couple songs
well Taryn is it Sammy and I feel like
he's a very underrated talent he seems
like a Renaissance man the more things I
learn about him people always go him as
a guy from Kingsman first off in
Kingsman he just plays a lot drama chops
physicality he did stop working that
like when you there's moments of like
pretty much like parkour maneuvers or
you're like damn looking [ __ ] go sing
oh sing yeah yeah talent show animal
enemy yeah he performed in that his
performance and Eddie and the eagle was
great its total transformation
performance in that one so handing over
the reins to him to play elton john it
is just like it's a promotional piece
this is nuts to me you might never see
rammie rammie malik play doing it
because he didn't sing him them yeah
that's all that someone's an insult to
his
performance in the film it's just for
promotional that's what I was saying
during the reaction like is this has
this been done before we're someone
who's playing as a singer is performing
with him onstage like this you know and
especially before the movie too because
I can think of times where you know like
oh maybe after like it kind of this
reminded me of when the greatest showman
like when the DVD was starting to come
out and they were releasing all the like
this is the first time they sang this
song yeah or whatever and it kind of
reminded me of that's like that's the
cast of the movie and Hugh Jackman is
there so for some of them that's a huge
honor but like this is Elton John is is
you know prolific and he's got this huge
status in the music you know history in
the lead-up to the movie too you know it
it seems clear that yeah they just like
each other and I mean this is Elton
John's according to the title of this
Elton John AIDS Foundation Academy
Awards viewing party he always he's
known for his Academy Awards bar yeah he
is but this is his foundation we all
know how the job produced the movie but
this just shows an extra sign of faith
that Elton John has in him and portray
him for the film people were the
confirmation came out that Taron Egerton
is doing the vocals it's not gonna be
you know he's not lip singing it if
people automatically
yeah just like course he's not this is
something like oh man like I was not
expecting to be blown away by oh my god
is looking for yes this is I didn't I
didn't even think this was gonna happen
ever you know yeah well I think to at
least with the voice thing you know
there are different tiers of it I
understand it more and I've come to
understand it more with Broadway
specifically but especially like Elton
John kind of has his own voice there's a
lot to the kid like the character that
is Elton John so I think there are
things for him to embody beyond just the
quality of his singing voice you know
even if he is not the best singer ever
he's still proven himself quite
competent with this kind of music and
you know Elton John has the costumes has
the life as well I mean this definitely
got me excited just yeah for the
prospect of the movie and I hope that it
is of a quality I hope that it's not
disingenuous that's the only thing I I
hope like other than its being good you
know just because of all that stuff with
oh he me
Rhapsody him being a producer feels like
with the amount of vulnerability that
Elton John puts on display a lot of the
time that it won't be I get a good
feeling you know like yeah I want I want
to be optimist they're gonna
fictionalized some stuff you know
whatever its way all biopics go I feel
like they'll be willing to show a lot
more of the darker shades of his journey
I would hope so and who he was at times
so yeah I mean I'm excited for this man
but I got I got it was great dude thanks
for requesting that for us but that was
uh something special Chris you know
where to follow him on Instagram and
also uh his YouTube channel is just his
name but seriously the astrologist
segment is amazing this guy I talked
back and forth quite an awful lot
handsome Canadian fella and I'm just
very friendly guy will keep on talking
dude Chris love you buddy thank you I
know I usually track home something
funny but sincerest thanks to you do
much love subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon man allows us anything you
guys do actually not go just go follow
any youtuber that has a patreon page if
you really love and go support